Die Hinweise auf außerirdisches Leben werden
immer erdrückender!
Ein Experiment eines Wiener Forschungsteams
legt jetzt nahe, dass auf der minus 200 Grad
Celsius kalten Eis-Oberfläche von Enceladus
Leben existieren könnte.
Die Fachleute hatten die Bedingungen auf dem
Saturnmond in aufwändigen Labor-Experimenten
simuliert.
Dabei entpuppte sich ein japanischer Einzeller
als wahrer Überlebenskünstler.
Doch es gibt eine riesige Gefahr!
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen!
Lebensfeindlicher als die Umgebung auf dem
Saturnmond Enceladus kann es auf den ersten
Blick erst einmal gar nicht sein.
Denn seine Oberfläche ist eisbedeckt und
es herrschen Temperaturen von minus 200 Grad
Celsius.
Doch mit Hilfe der NASA-Sonde “Cassini”
hatten Forschungsteams herausfinden können,
dass sich unter der dicken Eisschicht ein
kilometer-tiefer Ozean befindet.
Der Grund dafür sind wahrscheinlich Gezeiteneffekte
des Saturns.
Zudem treten aus Rissen in der Nähe des Enceladus-Südpols
tausende Kilometer hohe Dampf Fontänen heraus.
Und diese enthalten tatsächlich ALLE wichtigen
Zutaten für Leben: Stickstoffverbindungen
wie Methan, Ethan, Butan und Pentan und Salze,
aber auch Wasser, Sauerstoff und Kohlenstoff.
Forschende gehen deshalb davon aus, dass es
auf dem Meeresgrund von Enceladus heiße Quellen
gibt - mit Temperaturen von bis zu 100 Grad
Celsius.
Orte, an denen es auch hier auf der Erde vor
Leben nur so wimmelt.
Vor allem Methan gilt als wichtiger Hinweis
darauf, dass auf dem Saturnmond Enceladus
Leben existieren könnte.
Denn dieses Spurengas entsteht hauptsächlich
bei biologischen Prozessen unter Luftabschluss,
die auf Mikroorganismen zurückzuführen sind.
Somit gilt Methan schon seit langer Zeit als
Biomarker bei der Suche nach Leben in unserem
Sonnensystem.
Ein aktuelles Experiment eines Wiener Forschungsteams
zeigt jetzt, dass mikrobielles Leben - wie
wir es von unserer Erde her kennen - auch
auf Enceladus möglich sein könnte.
Dazu nutzten die Fachleute Mikroorganismen
aus der Gruppe der Archaea, die extreme Bedingungen
wie hohe Temperaturen und Druck aushalten.
Diese Mikroben mit der Bezeichnung “Methanothermococcus
okinawensis” kommen vor allem in der Okinawa-Senke
vor, sich fast 1.000 Meter unter dem Meeresspiegel
befindet - ein eigentlich lebensfeindlicher
Ort.
Zudem verstoffwechseln diese Mikroorganismen,
die in der Fachsprache auch “Methanogene”
genannt werden, Wasserstoff und Kohlendioxid.
Konkret nutzen sie molekularen Wasserstoff
(H2) als Energiequelle und Kohlendioxid (CO2)
als Kohlenstoff- und Energiequelle, um Methan
(CH4) zu metabolisieren, also um daraus ihre
Energie zu gewinnen.
Dazu der Biotechnologe Simon Rittmann, der
an der Studie beteiligt war: “Insbesondere
ein Stamm aus der japanischen Tiefsee, der
an sehr hohe Temperaturen und hohen Druck
angepasst ist, war besonders geeignet”.
In ihrem Experiment bauten die Fachleute also
die möglichen Bedingungen des Saturnmondes
Enceladus nach und analysierten dann vereinfacht
gesagt, wie hoch die Methan-Produktivität
der Methanogene war.
In den Experimenten zeigten sich schnell,
dass diese Mikroorganismen unter den Bedingungen,
die der Saturnmond bietet, sogar vermehrungsfähig
sind.
Die Experimente wurden sehr aufwändig gestaltet
und so wurden auch die astronomisch-geologischen
und die chemisch-physikalischen Bedingungen,
die vermutlich unter dem Eismantel des Saturnmondes
herrschen, simuliert.
Und das Ergebnis ist eindeutig.
Simon Rittmann fasst es so zusammen: “Wir
haben gezeigt, dass Methanogene unter Enceladus-ähnlichen
Bedingungen vermehrungsfähig sind und ein
Teil des in den Wassereis-Fontänen nachgewiesenen
CH4 daher prinzipiell biologischen Ursprungs
sein könnte.“
Wow!
Selbst bei einem Druck von 50 Bar waren die
japanischen Tiefsee-Mikroben noch in der Lage,
sich zu vermehren.
Bei einem noch höheren Druck allerdings nahm
ihre Aktivität ab.
Das im Labor simulierte Enceladus-Meer zeigte
aber auch, dass sich auch noch weitere Archaea
vermehren konnten.
Das Forschungsteam aus Wien schließt daraus,
dass "Eismonde wie Enceladus oder der Jupitermond
Europa, der ebenfalls einen unterirdischen
Ozean besitzt" gute Aussichten bieten, außerirdisches
Leben zu entdecken.
Vielleicht sogar noch bessere als der Mars,
auf dem der Exomars-Satellit ja derzeit nach
Methanquellen sucht.
Klar ist dabei aber auch zu berücksichtigen,
dass die Bedingungen, die nun im Labor nachgestellt
wurden, nicht unbedingt 1:1 denen des unterirdischen
Wasser-Ozeans auf Enceladus entspricht, trotz
des riesigen Aufwands.
Bestimmte Biosignaturen wie beispielsweise
Lipide oder bestimmte Isotopen-Verhältnisse
könnten langfristig gesehen aber dabei helfen,
methanbildendes Leben auf dem Enceladus aufzuspüren
und diese Vermutung ein für allemal zu belegen.
Doch die aktuelle Studie aus Wien macht auch
noch eine andere Sache deutlich: Raumsonden
von der Erde stellen möglicherweise eine
große Gefahr da.
Denn sie könnten Eismonde wie Enceladus im
schlimmsten Fall mit irdischen Organismen
kontaminieren, weil diese eben unter den Extrembedingungen
überleben könnten.
Und noch eine andere Frage ist super spannend:
Bestehen Aliens aus Fleisch und Blut?
Hier geht‘s zum Video.
Unbedingt anklicken, anschauen und unbedingt
Neugierzone Wissenschaft gewissenhaft abonnieren!
Ich zähle auf euch!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!